uh here's a guy who tries desperately to
be shocking lil na's ex
he appeared on the breakfast club radio
show
and um one question that he gets a lot
and for good reason is
what about the what about the kids uh
and the reason why he gets this question
is because he's he started with that
terrible song old town road
which was an awful song a really stupid
song it was
i can't even say that it was a that it
was uh
i'm saying it's awful and stupid as a
song but it was also inappropriate for
kids if you look at the lyrics but
mainly was just a really dumb song
but
kids loved it and he he very
intentionally marketed to kids he he
went to elementary schools and middle
schools and performed he performed on
nickelodeon and all these things and he
garnered this intentionally garnered
this audience of young children
and then did a bait and switch
and started putting out graphic
satanic literally satanic music
and um he was asked asked about that on
the breakfast club morning show here's
his answer
parents would be like you know you have
a responsibility because kids are
watching you hear that cardi b had that
same problem and nikki had that same
problem do you feel that same way like
how does your own kids i feel like i
used to but now just like
so
like like [ __ ] your kids not like your
kids
that's exactly what you just said
but
okay what agenda is that the kid's
agenda
it's like um
we really get one one chance to do this
at least to my knowledge i don't know
like what happens when we die or not uh
so it's like i'm not
i'm not like about to pander to your
kids or you
like anybody like even i have even have
to do this with my family members you
know like because my family members may
not always agree with what i'm doing or
like whoever i'm dating like they may
not agree but it's like
i honestly really truly want to live by
you know this is our life we get to do
this so
what anybody else has to really say
about it i guess you know i would say
when it comes to the music just tell
people that's the reason there's a
parental advisory sticker that too on on
the music did you see the youtube kids
thing you know i don't know if you saw
that
it was like a lady she's like she like
searched up
music for babies oh i saw that and they
said something like that like industry
baby popped up and she was like
surprised like you looked up baby and
music and music like what do you what do
you expect from that
yeah like uh like
like i'm gonna do what i want like and
that's like what i'm just gonna do is
what i want and like that's how i'm
gonna live like
what does it say about our culture that
this guy with an iq of 42.
i mean i've i've had
caesar salads at applebee's that had a
higher iq than this guy and he's a
he's a big star and how do you get a big
start it's just like he wears dresses
and walks around in dresses and everyone
goes well it's revolutionary he's a
brilliant artist
every every male artist is wearing
dresses now
there's either who is it i think it's
russell westbrook
nba stars are now walking around in
dresses
and they still want to convince us that
this is
some sort of brilliant
boundary breaking thing
but his answer
so far as it could be translated and
understood was f your kids
and that's how he feels about it
um
these people are all
speaking of soulless they're all
soulless sociopaths
and they they just simply don't care
they do not care about your kids
they feel no responsibility at all
to anyone but themselves they they are
this is
why it is so appropriate that um he put
out that satanic video where he's you
know uh twerking on satan's lap
because although he meant it to be
partly satirical or
however he would justify it
he is a satanist and that he belongs in
the religion of himself he is a
self-worshiper and
he said it there
very clearly nothing else in the world
matters nobody else matters only me
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated